congratulations on overcoming the trials  facing mankind and fighting the  administrator you defeated Flores and  are about to go to a whole new world may  things be peaceful and happy this time  around nice ears up and running again  and that monster at the sky tower looked  a lot like acceptance reality the  creature that appeared today is one of  the Triangulum no it can't be it's all  the same as the previous four out what  are we supposed to do there's no way  that you need something that strong the  fate of the world is pretty much in our  hands right now I never thought we'd get  caught up in a fight to save humanity  like this the sky tower Falls our world  will  you will likely find yourself pressed  with such a decision one day  and that time comes please don't let me  down